we got some you know the bad news this
weekend and I know that he holds a
special place in your heart can you talk
to us a bit about how you felt when you
heard the news how you're feeling now I
felt that it was a big a big hole that
will be left in show business and then
I'm saying not just country music but
this guy was an incredible actor this
guy had as many contacts in Nashville as
he did in New York as he did in LA you
know what I was watching stranger things
last night like episode 3 of season 2
and they're talking about Kenny Rogers
like this is a guy that dominated the
70s and the 80s but also I stood the
test of time whereas a show that was
filmed in 2019 still understands that
this guy is one of the kings of the
music business and that of course is
relationship with Dolly Parton and
islands in the stream and stuff like
that it's um it's amazing the legacy
he's left and he's left a big hole don't
just punch your music but in show
business yeah you have a close
connection to him as well right yeah
personal I I had a very unique encounter
with him I'm not sure if you maybe had a
chance there to read this story on on
Instagram but one of my first trips to
Nashville by myself um he he walked in
and was sitting at a booth at this
breakfast spot across from me so we
could see each other and he was there
alone drinking coffee and he ordered a
Reuben sandwich which was a very odd
thing to order in the morning but
everybody ordered it and he was reading
the USA Today and I was waiting on a
producer to come in and meet with me
my producer never showed up and I sat
there by myself just sipping on some
orange juice for an hour until Kenny
Rogers stood up and he looked at me and
said you look like an artist I said yeah
I'm gonna artist and he said it also
looks like you've been stood up and I
said yeah it looks that way he said
welcome to the music business son really
cool thing like Kenny Rogers you know
say that Bobby my breakfast and I told
the waitress says whatever the kid wants
it's on me
and and he walked away just like that
this I caught it legend bought me
breakfast then I feel that in some ways
he and a bunch of other legends I've
been able to meet over the years I've
kind of had their hands on my shoulders
guiding me in a spiritual way